the Joe Rogan experience doo-doo-doo-doo
we should honestly guys it might not be
this year about the [ __ ] you know media
stuff your wedding is next you gonna
take that dead gay [ __ ] tape back up I'm
gonna shoot some hot ones into you I
love you so much
I got my dick fixed that's really up you
might have hiked reconnected yeah they
pulled the straw out of one of those sea
turtles noses and they use it to fix my
dick you know this drop video with the
sea turtles knows no it's the most
horrific video it's the reason why they
don't have plastic rod up if you like
why the [ __ ] do we have plastic cups two
lids why don't we have plastic straws
the reason why is because there's a
[ __ ] video of a turtle and they have
a clamp I don't know if this is the main
reason but it is for a lot of people
yeah clamp this straw in this turtles
mouth and they eventually pulled it in
his turtles nose rather it was deep in
his nose yes you can like one of those
so see that's a that's a stray gonna
tell you that got stuck it is see so
much is harder it is so much harder to
watch this happen to animals than to
people how do we not know this wasn't a
night of cocaine gone wrong look at that
poor turtle so he inhaled this yeah good
one so they realize that the straw was
stuck and apparently this is not a
little eating it's this isn't is not an
unusual thing so they have to put weight
what do they boys our guy get a real
tweezer guys and he's scared and just
got he's got little hands - he's got
little [ __ ] Thai hands little bit
Jeff's hands grab it and pull the eyes
out there save and turn holder funded
themselves about this person's hands or
Turtles going no look at it oh it's his
brain looks like Jim Jim Norton's going
no don't do it
he's in a pocketknife well that's all
he's got you know I would bite it with
my face and I would pull it out with my
neck because you're a warrior
someone hold it's [ __ ] hair about the
animals I care about the animals I'm a
warrior for sea creatures there
this has got to get it right the [ __ ]
scales got a leather man or that is I
know this guy's not take horrible I
never play operation was this grow it
takes time but it's worth it at the end
oh he's trying to bite the show he's
like what are you guys doing to me who's
behind it's better before leave me a lot
oh he's bleeding out of his [ __ ] nose
how did they get to see charwoman bogies
and notice in the first place guy you
stop being a [ __ ] grab here goes
no no he's trying to [ __ ] pull you
just gotta eventually gets it he
eventually gets a swirlies show me this
show I'm getting it this too hard
ok the videos almost done so this is
look hard that's gone they're gonna take
that out and they gonna stick it in
ari's dick hole the fixes they should do
they should recycle it to open up your
dick pipe new the fish they take that
rock out that calcified dick Rock yeah
make it a nice ring that is really
romantic pipe with the actual tube that
they pulled out of that turtles nose
there are some diamonds in there too
you know because you're dead pipes on
tlingit fling it out yeah why not
what if we each raise a direwolf like
something
[Applause]